zendaya is one of the few artists that
we can just vibe with especially during
all the embarrassing and awkward moments
she stumbled through she just seems to
attract the awkward at times and we
can't help but enjoy it so let's all
cringe together through this at least
now we can share in her awkwardness
number one you ever hear a certain noise
and think it's one thing but then it
ends up being something entirely bizarre
it looks like zendaya certainly has and
this one involves skin-tight suits and a
whole lot of gas the scene in question
involves spider-man dropping nj off on a
bridge structure and taking a call from
ned the gas in question comes from a
skin-tight suit pressing on tom
holland's intestines zendaya was not
really fazed at first given holland was
quick to say the little rattle was just
the harness vibrating she was able to
buy this excuse for a little while until
tom holland finally fessed up to his
crime yeah i farted on me unfortunately
yeah it's tough number two there is
nothing wrong with zendaya and holland's
height difference but sometimes it can
get a little embarrassing for her during
stunt sequences this one really
coincides with our previous entry here
which really just mashes a whole lot of
embarrassing stories into one
let's save me mj
now zendaya is a few inches taller than
her on and off-screen lover tom which
created quite the conundrum for them
when landing on the ground we were
initially thinking what's so hard about
landing in harnesses well when you're
taller than someone and that's certain
someone is supposed to land their feet
on the ground before you it's going to
make you feel pretty silly number three
we all know the embarrassment that can
follow a wisdom tooth removal but how
about kissing someone during a super
important audition poor zendaya had to
get hers removed shortly before
auditioning with timothy chalamet for
dune and being that you can't do a whole
lot of cleaning after such a procedure
she was embarrassed to even open her
mouth to put it lightly zindaya recounts
her encounters saying my biggest fear
was that my mouth would be vile and then
i would have to do a scene with timothy
where we would have to be really close
and he would smell my possible dry
socket breath
number four zendaya seems to really
relish in her most embarrassing moments
and for that we certainly applaud her
for it she shared a hilarious image of
her dangling in the air with peter
parker and she did not look so enthused
to be up there and the embarrassing part
in new york you can't lock off the
streets so there's just people like
hanging out so she had all eyes on her
and since she can laugh at it so can we
number five there was a lot for zendaya
to do in the greatest showman and most
of it was done upside down being that
this was her first time tackling the
whole trapeze art form we'd think she'd
be more concerned about not breaking any
bones but no cinderia harped on being
more embarrassed about the way she
looked hanging upside down i have this
huge vein just right down my forehead
number six she just had quite the ride
on the greatest showman with trouble on
the trapeze and now being blamed for gas
by wolverine himself
no one thought that wasn't you
poor cinder was already nervous as she
was acting in front of hugh jackman but
when someone just let one rip while she
was up in the air everyone took notice
as a professional i was gonna carry on
it was not me number seven there are way
too many pigeons invading zendaya's
personal bubble here and oh does she
look extremely uncomfortable here
there's so many
movements
it looks like she was counting on her
luck to not get her eyes pecked out
number eight zendaya has always watched
out for her own personal beliefs on and
off the camera even when she was first
starting out on disney channel's shake
it up she put her foot down on
showmaker's requests although the scenes
in question were never officially named
zendaya stated that she would never
share her first kiss on screen she
remained adamant throughout the entire
show explaining i'm not gonna do this
i'm going to kiss him on the cheek
because i haven't been kissed yet so i
don't want the kiss to be on camera she
is and was one of the strongest young
actors of her time number nine with an
already busy schedule zendaya really
never got a break the day after
returning from the venice film festival
she was slated to shoot the intervention
scene in season 2 episode 5 of euphoria
and everyone who watched this tough
scene could feel all the chaotic energy
she had put into the moment we can't
imagine how uncomfortable it must have
been to film a scene like that berating
some of your closest off and on-screen
friends but she got through it and she
stated it wasn't all that simple saying
it was so intense and scary to tackle
and absolutely something that would be
incredibly emotionally taxing
number 10 wouldn't it just be a little
awkward passing out in the middle of a
scene well zendaya almost did most of
euphoria season 2 made even some of the
strongest actors uncomfortable and
unfortunately for zendaya she had a lot
of them this one in particular involved
her dodging cars in the california heat
which just makes for a double trouble of
a time the heat just made her feel more
disoriented and after coming back from a
desert shoot for dune she was pretty
much over it show creators would
definitely keep safety at its forefront
but zendaya still felt that something
catastrophic could have happened here
number 11 talk about uncomfortable this
one had us cringing at every word she
said yeah there's there's there was some
chafing for sure sand and skin tight
suits were all we needed to know about
zendaya's experiences on the set of dune
but she alludes to the fact that suits
pretty much sealed out the sand pretty
much yeah it's pretty sealed up no
sealed up the time sometimes you you
want it number 12 zendaya and tom are so
adorable and little did we know that our
two awkward spidey characters were
feeling the embarrassment on set and
spider-man far from home we got to see
peter and mj's relationship take a huge
step and they got a lot of alone time
together so knowing now that they are
both a couple in real life and they
didn't want others to know at the time
these scenes struggled for them because
they were well
awkward we had to do the scene and then
we'd have to stop and let like traffic
go through these stop and go experiences
probably made them a little
uncomfortable with the constant
speculation of the relationship from the
cast and crew
number 13 there's no way you'd catch any
of us doing this uncomfortable bit
zendaya must have really trusted the
crew to make sure she was safe in this
spidey stunt because apparently all it
would take is a couple of boxes to break
her fall there's like these empty boxes
stacked together and i was like that's
it that's all we got she wasn't so sure
about the 110 foot drop but she finally
found the courage to do it but in the
end it was never even necessary the
thing is they didn't end up using that
okay we re-shot it stunt coordinators
ended up opting for a much more
comfortable stunt for zendaya one that
was a mere four feet above the ground
number fourteen you can't always rely on
gravity to keep you safe and these kinds
of stunts are really hard this
embarrassing moment comes from the
greatest showman as ann and philip
declare their love for each other while
swinging on ropes there was a lot of
graceful colliding in the final cut but
did you know it took them a bunch of
painful times to get it right it's
beautiful and that's great but
if you don't catch each other the end
result proves zac efron and zendaya
eventually got it right but it seems
like this was one of the top most
embarrassing moments for her on the set
of the greatest showman
number 15. in this instance we really
can't imagine how zendaya would have
been able to follow up holland's amazing
performance on this memorable lip sync
battle no matter how extra she went it
seemed like nothing could stop him from
winning every time and it doesn't help
her case here that tom does indeed have
dancing experience and a certain flair
of extra in his performance this girl is
an absolute star on the silver screen
not only is she one of the most talented
actresses of the past decade but she's
shown us that we can still be a little
awkward at times so how would you have
reacted to wolverine blaming you for a
little gas let us know awkwardly below
and as always thanks for watching the
things